jurors are expected to begin
deliberations today in the criminal
trial of disgraced movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
with more on this story Jericka good
morning to you what arguments where will
the jury consider today well the
arguments from both sides you know the
prosecutors call Harvey Weinstein a
serial rapist and master manipulator
while the defense accuses prosecutors at
being producers creating what they call
an alternative universe at this point it
will be in the jury hands Harvey
Weinstein's legal team appeared
confident on Friday nearly two years
after the former Hollywood studio chief
turned himself over to police charged
with sexual assault rape and predatory
sexual assault in the cases of two
alleged victims he denies all
accusations and insists this was all
consensual sex since Weinstein's trial
began last month the prosecution called
on for additional accusers to establish
a pattern of criminal misconduct now a
jury comprised of seven men and five
women will determine if that effort was
successful when you have six accusers
who are telling somewhat similar stories
about how Harvey Weinstein acted in
essence is a predatory monster then you
have a strong case we spoke with CBS
News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman who
broke down the jury's wrote ahead when
you look at those two main witnesses do
you see there being room for the jurors
to have reasonable doubt there is always
room for jurors to have reasonable doubt
when you've had vigorous
cross-examination in this particular
case you also have the circumstances of
each of the two New York accusers having
long-term relationship with Harvey
Weinstein this jury may take a long time
because there's a lot of evidence in
this case what does this trial represent
for the me2 movement that's the elephant
in the room isn't it you've been able to
see protesters outside you've seen a
packed courtroom this isn't just about
Harvey Weinstein and these jurors know
it
if convicted on all five counts
Weinstein faces up to life in prison and
even if this case is decided either way
he still faces sexual assault charges in
Los Angeles Tony yes no more trials to
come juries can be unpredictable we'll
be following that drinka thank you very
much